We have a voicemail number. That number is two one
nine two. David P. Here is another caller saying,
David, you really don't need to be giving
these disclaimers. Take a listen to this.
Hi, my name is Sam, and I was just watching
your show, and you talked about the David
and the Goldman Sachs predictions and
you spent a whole 30 seconds still on.
You know, they were really good at these
predictions and that's why I'm using them.
You don't have to like Goldman
Sachs and blah, blah, blah.
And I think you could do it more efficiently. But
the saying, you know, Goldman Sachs makes these
really good predictions. It's kind of like how
Fox News has good polling around the election. You
don't have to like Fox News, but they're just good
at that job. And I think everybody would get it.
And I think that's where the caller
is wrong. Not everybody would get it.
There is a contingent in my audience. It's the
same people who write to me and say, David,
why did you support the coup in Bolivia, which,
of course, I never did. And and if I just said
very interesting prediction by Goldman Sachs
and they do good predictions and I just go on,
I will get 100 hundred emails, maybe four
maybe for something like this. It's 50,
not 100 from people saying, how
dare you as a supposed progressive,
cite Goldman Sachs as if they're anything
but the epitome of what is terrible about.
So I give the disclaimer now I know I'm playing
to the lowest common denominator when I do it,
but I do it for my own sanity because
otherwise you should see what my inbox
looks like. OK, I wish I didn't need
the where the caller is wrong is.
In saying, I don't need the disclaimers, I wish I
didn't need them, but I do need them for the for
the sanity of my inbox. We have a great bonus show
for you today. Texas Rangers home baseball opener,
40000 fans sitting side by side, wild, wild
times. Janet Yellen, treasury secretary, calling
for a minimum global corporate income tax. And I'm
going to talk about the little Noss X controversy,
OK, on today's bonus show, get instant
access by becoming a member at joint dotcom.